hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge von
reis auf ukulele letzte folge wieder
anderthalb wochen her ich hab mir dann
deswegen gedacht ich mache mache noch
eine hier was geht an alle die letzten
folgen wahrscheinlich zusammen geschaut
denken sich gerade wieder rechts
gelaufen von der kommt er doch alles
klar ich bin einfach dumm wir töten hier
den lukas meili und nochmal den lukas
meili und nochmal in lukas meili unten
nochmal den lukas meili
es ist eigentlich richtig traurig weil
wir die ganze zeit quasi luca töten ich
find's cool und ukulele hier oben auch
schaden nehmen könnte weil die verb wo
er sei die ukulele opulent wahlen link
versteckt im schrank weil werten
geburtstagsparty und dann habe ich alles
versteckt dass sie mir wichtig ist die
letzte folge war schon bisher das habe
ich mir gedacht ich mach mir noch ein
und es kommt auch gut bei euch an
ich bin so ein guter spieler was würdet
ihr davon halten wenn ich irgendwann mal
einen ukulelen die klebt doch jetzt
nicht wirklich da an der fucking decke
fest oder ich meine was würdet ihr euch
denken wir nur kollege auf einmal mitten
an der wand kleben würde ich hätte lust
meine kollegin song zu machen aber ich
weiß nicht ob top oder ein album am
besten mit mit drei mit schreibt mir
einfach mal in die stimmt ich kann ja
auch noch ballern
wieso kann ich dann ein fucking wand
hängen bleiben welche das vergessen wie
ich den slow motion modus es war so klar
es war ja so klar ich habe ehrlich
gesagt vergessen wie ich den slow motion
modus aktivieren deswegen habe ich das
vergessen haut mal ich mach das ja nie
mit likes aber daran kann man immer
sehen wie wichtig wie sehr man sollten
was will sage ich mal deswegen haut mal
weiß fest ich etwas nennt man da ich
gucke mir nicht leicht an wie viel soll
ich sagen was sind viele weil sie nicht
gebe mir zehn millionen oder so wie viel
ist der realistische andere youtuber
immer so sagen ja mal gebt mir 100000
likes dann spring ich zum fenster weil
ich mich so freue weil alles sind auf
der welt ja weiß nicht keine ahnung
bleibt das video wenn ihr bock habt auf
dem kollegen zogen dann sehe ich dass
daran weil kommentare und die ganze bin
ich denn zu dumm die kommentarfunktion
auf youtube scrap und da findet man doch
einfach nichts und das ist kacke und an
den likes kann man einfach ganz simpel
ihn sehen
das ist gerade geschafft haben einfach
sehen ok ja die wollen da sind er will
das auf und der will das nicht und was
genau ist wissen eigentlich macht
einfach ein bisschen wissen ein bisschen
den abwehr so in angriff habe ich
tatsächlich noch gar nichts gesteckt ich
meine es wird ja dann keinen keinen
album was ihr kaufen könnte es wird halt
ach du heilige scheiße
wie mache ich jetzt noch mal den
zeitlupen modus ich weiß nicht wo ich
nicht ausweichen solle mir kommt es so
vor als ob die teile mich irgendwie
verfolgen ball war das ist super spitze
ich komme auf jeden fall nicht mehr weg
ich kann noch nicht mal irgendwohin
hochspringen ich meine dass da hinten
sehr viel zu hoch die teile gehen auf
dem boden halte ich lass einfach den
slow motion modus an man diese vita lust
hat kann ich einfach auch die ganze zeit
gar nur nach halbes leben ich mache das
nicht so wie andere youtuber laut dann
auch auf itunes oder so raus weil ich
will nicht mit scheiße geld verdienen
und das wird halt scheiße und viele
tolle sachen voll hinter stehen und es
gibt genug youtuber die scheiß musik für
viel geld verkaufen
das wird dann halt einfach so ein video
wo ich auf youtube was ich da hoch laden
wo ich dann zehn kleine songs mache die
eine halbe minute gehen meint vielleicht
wird es ja witzig ich habe keine ahnung
salz konzentrieren uns hier wieder aufs
spiel damit ich jetzt erstmal schön oh
mein gott oh mein gott wie stichwahl
bitte dieser jump gerade nein nein
vitello jura und krieg dieses spiel ist
so schwer ich dachte halt ehrlich wenn
ich euch sagen ja ich will und coolen
spiel das dann so was kommt wie oh mein
gott schon wieder tot dass seine
komplette gehalt kommt ist eher so wie
ein ferrari oder so ich meine es ist ja
auch eigentlich so aber es ist trotzdem
so fucking schwer jetzt springe ich hier
über und springe hier rein und da ist
der check von oh mein gott
die slow motion weg um so heftiger
erstmal steht mir das blöde ding da oben
haben und bevor sie teile hier treffen
werden wir einfach mal wieder nach ganz
rechts wandern und hoffen dass uns
keiner von diesen schweinen auf den kopf
mein gott da comdirect schon einer das
komische ding davon ist weg das heißt
ich habe jetzt wieder die slow motion
rein und jetzt werden wir einfach mal
war das eng man kann das ab jetzt nur
noch in slow motion machen so kommen
aber ich fühle mich bei slow mein gott
was fällt diesem stein ein alter ich
fühle mich beim orscheler wie so ein
hacker weil alles halt in slow motion
ist oh mein gott freunde ich weiß
überhaupt nicht mehr wohin soll diese
verdammt noch mal schwer geworden alter
es ist einfach nicht wahr ich warte bis
dieses ding da tod ist genau lasse ich
hier alles mal eben runter purzeln dir
danach mein gott jetzt sind hier schon
ich glaub's ja nicht und das teil da
oben ist tot
ich will einfach noch einen checkpoint
man jetzt wo mein gott ok nein nein nein
nein nein es wird immer schwieriger ja
wahrscheinlich sind da unten diese
taktik ab wo ich einfach die ganze zeit
dran verrät ihr scheiß missgeburten man
hüpft ihr weiter ich spring hier hoch so
wartet ich warte hier und jetzt hier
über ihn drüber und hier hin und gibt
mir einfach ein checkpoint da ist ein
schießt mich ruhig alle ab es ist mir
egal ich habe einen checkpoint an dieser
stelle würde ich sagen meine damen ich
beende das ganze video weil es gerade
schon wieder halb eins nachts ist nicht
morgen nach berlins lee als wenn ihr das
wiedersehen fliege ich nach berlin
morgens und wenn es euch gefällt hat ich
würde mich über den damen freuen wenn
ihr dieses mal ein paar ukulele lieder
die ich werde wahrscheinlich zu machen
wie of puppets so ein bisschen so ein
bisschen random nein ich sterbe gerade
schon wieder rein bleibt gesund fangen
nicht an zu rauchen